i'm sorry i think your things are in my
seat sorry
oh come on you've got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am i need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worst 19
years of my life we were only married
for five i'm counting the recovery
in four days our daughter's gonna marry
a guy she just met bali millions of
miles from home i just really wanna kiss
you
it's like i looked up for the first time
and realized everything i ever wanted
was right in front of me
she's throwing her career away just like
her mother did so i'm the only one who
can stop her she doesn't listen to him
champagne oh too please just leave the
bottle
thank you
[Applause]
i won't let her throw her life away we
need to trick her into dumping him as
much as this will paint us both we have
to call a truce to make this work you
have to be in lockstep
did you make a pact to not murder each
other until you murder me first we are
here for you my love yes we're lost
promise no mean comments pretty sure you
don't win anything for eating the whole
pig no arguing
no passive aggression what about
aggressive aggression try to keep the
snoring down i have a nasal strip ah
it's a mystery you're still alone
mom dad this is g'day um
hey
you learned that to make me look bad you
don't need my help there
are you sure they're not sharks come on
don't be a chicken you might be working
with the sharks
i can't believe i got bit by a dolphin
when i do that with you he said pressure
so what's the plan i say we steal the
rings
[Music]
how they look disappointed
do you think we're wrong or not wrong
who are we to say that lily doesn't know
what's best for herself
[Music]
oh my god i cannot believe you what are
you talking about she found the rings
where in mom's bag
i knew it what
you clean up pretty good
there you go it's not for the faint of
heart this is not his first rodeo okay
let's go let's go can we get something a
little more age-appropriate for these
two
here we go which one there's only one i
see two
oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no dad please stop doing that
oh my god
i'm praying for an asteroid
[Music]